- Are there any brands out
there that you look at and say
ugh that is an iconic brand that has
meant so much in history but
today it means nothing?
I'd love to get my hands on it.
- Nintendo.
- Why?
- Because they're fucking up.
There's no 15-year-old the fact that
Nintendo's not winning in
app gaming is ludicrous.
They have the IP.
The fact that Kardashian apps and
Minecraft and other things
are winning while there isn't a
15-year-old that gives a
crap anymore about Mario or
Zelda or things of that nature,
that was a huge miss.
And they got romantic that it
was all about the console where
they made their money and they
were romantic and they didn't
deploy against the
next attention place
and they allowed that
romance to kill them.